[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اخواني
الحمد لله على السلامه
يلا الحمد لله على السلامه
[موسيقى]
كنت ابحث عن سؤال عن شعور الشخص الذي
ينادي ينادي ينادي ولا يسمع احد ووجدته
عندك صعب شعور كانك ميت حي يعني ميت حي
انا كنت عايشه بس كنت خلاص فقدت الامل اني
راح اموت ما حدا رح يطلعني يعني كتير
اتشاهد اذكر الله اخاف اولادي اضمهم اخاف
هدول اللي عايشين مع اني يموتوا اخاف انه
ما حدا يسمعني
جرح كبير براسي وهون وبظهري بس الحمد لله
يعني يعتبر الم خفيف بالنسبه للالم القلب
اني فائده فلزت كبدي بنتي الوحيده فاطمه
فاطمه
اسمعني
ابدا اول لحظه وقع البيت
يعني وبتسمع وانت
مسافه 20 متر تسمع اصوات
الاشخاص من تحت الابنيه بس ما تحسن تتحرك
لانه ما هديت كتير ناس ماتت من خوفه وفزع
على الدراج
من الذي يتواجد تحت الانقاض تحت اللحظه
موجود ابن عمي
وابن صاحب المكتب كمان ورفيقهم بس لحد
هاللحظه هن موجودين لانه الكشف الحراري
انا انه في ثلاث جثث جوا
يلا
عمو مثل القنابل مثل القذائف على راسي
بطلت اسمع بطلت اشوف